it's been nearly eight months since
government forces
literally locked out juan guaydol from
venezuela's national assembly
this even though he was the leader of
parliament
now president nicolas maduro is
preparing to make good on his vow to
regain control of parliament
the country's only independent
democratic institution
in upcoming elections in response guido
is issuing an
urgent call to opposition parties for
action
i propose a commitment to discuss and
agree on a common strategy in the next
10 days i will expect a public and
active answer from each of you
showing a united commitment to freeing
venezuela
guado's plan calls for denouncing and
rejecting what he calls
an electoral fraud
we must activate an agenda of domestic
and international action and
mobilization to obtain the necessary
responses from our armed forces
the international community and all of
our allies
is appealing to the fractured opposition
to join forces
and call for a total boycott of the
elections arguing that fraud is a
foregone conclusion
participating would legitimize a
dictatorship he says
a new data analysis poll suggests that
75
of venezuelans believe the elections
won't be competitive
and won't reflect the opinion of the
voters
when you ask people about their
disposition to vote in an election that
evidently
is not competitive only 11 percent say
that they are very willing to do so
and about 30 percent say that they may
that means around 40 percent might go to
the pools but past experience shows most
abstain
if conditions are unfair
given that sentiment the opposition is
clearly in a lose-lose position
has lost momentum leadership and the
ability to mobilize large numbers of
people as he once did
his bet is that by boycotting the poll
the opposition can at least
claim there was no election
that will likely draw out an ongoing
political standoff in which more than 50
nations recognize waida as venezuela's
legitimate interim president
but as he well knows even that can't
last
indefinitely cn newman al jazeera